-We're back with Hilary Duff.
This is very exciting.
-Below 60.
-Yeah.
-What would you
describe these as?
In-home fragrances?
-Yes I would.
I would say
they're in-home fragrances.
They're plug-ins.
-They're plug-ins.
-You know, we all kind of grew
up with said plug-in.
-Yes.
-They are updated, my friend.
-And you are the chief
brand director
for these fragrances.
-Which basically means
I get to be really bossy with
all the boys
that started the company.
-Oh, that's very nice.
-Yeah.
And I get to tell them
like, "I don't like that.
No, that sticks out
too far from the wall.
Change this, change that.
Oh, what about this scent?
Oh, that scent.
I like this thing together."
-And you seem like a very
fun person to work with.
[ Laughter ]
-It's a lot of texts.
It's a lot of rapid-fire texts.
-Oh, okay.
So it's all on texts.
-No, no, no.
We have meetings,
too, of course.
But, no, they're great.
-So, a lot of it
is how the product looks,
but a lot of it
must be the scents
and then also
the names of the scents.
First of all,
before I get to the names,
do you feel like you have
a good nose for this?
Have you been told over
the years that you do?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-I mean, by the way,
I'm always complimented by
like, the way
that I smell, so...
-Like, not by the way
you smell other things,
but the way
you actually smell.
-I smell other things
pretty well, too,
but that's because
I've been obsessed with
perfume and scents
for a long time.
-That's very --
So, you've been a --
I know those kind of people
that they walk in,
and everybody's like,
"Wow, you smell great."
That's happened to you
your whole life?
-Since I was a toddler, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
No, but since I started
buying perfume, I guess,
ever since the Cucumber Melon
from Bath & Body Works, guys.
-I was...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-People know.
But that -- Well, I'm glad
you made the distinction,
because you're not saying,
"Look, there's no one
could ever smell like me.
It comes from within."
You're basically saying
it is product-based.
-It's both, Seth. It's both.
-It's both.
You've got to have
a base coat of just being,
like, a good-smelling person.
-Yes. Yes.
-Yeah.
-I'm sweating.
[ Laughter ]
-And by the way, the more --
Can I just say?
The more you're smelling.
Yeah, it's, like --
It's outstanding.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, so, the names.
Are you coming up with
these names for these scents?
-Yeah. So, the product
is very, like, universal.
It can look great in any home.
It's really modern and updated.
And I was like,
"We got to give the --"
I mean, I'm the shopper
in my household.
I'm sure Alexi is the same.
-100%.
-She's the consumer.
We're buying for the house.
We're the ones
that get ad-targeted.
-Yeah.
-They get me every time.
And I was like,
"We got to hook people in.
Like, what is --
Let's give this a story."
Let's give these names like --
Let's be very playful with it."
Also, the scents last a month,
so, you know, when you're done
with it, you, like, refill
a cartridge with something else.
And it's just, like,
constantly evolving,
which is kind of my personality.
I'm always wanting
to try something new
and do something new.
So, yeah,
the names are very fun.
-I'm gonna read you some.
-Okay.
-If Citrus Were a Feeling.
-Mm-hmm.
-That's a very unique name
for a smell.
-Okay, are you judging
or do you like it?
[ Laughter ]
-I want you to take
"unique" home with you
and decide
what you think it means.
No, I like it,
but I like the better one.
I like the second one more.
-Okay.
-No, I'm going to put
my favorite one third.
Then Mint Disco on Ice.
-Mm-hmm.
-I like Mint Disco on Ice.
-Okay. You know what?
The men love that one.
-Do they really?
-Yeah. I don't know why men
love, like, mint
and, like, fresh
and, like, cooling and pine
and things like that.
-Well, now I feel
like you're judging.
-Well, I'm a little
judgmental of that one.
I think it's a little more
geared towards men, but...
-Gotcha. Alright.
-I love it. I still love it.
-Oh, nobody believes that.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, Seth.
-But here's the winner.
Vanilla Buys a Timeshare
in Paradise.
I mean, come on.
That is...
-Don't you want to buy it?
-That I want to buy.
And I don't even --
Like, vanilla would not be --
is not, like,
a top-three scent of mine,
but I have so much appreciation
for how that --
Now I'm using it in
the best way I possibly can.
That is incredibly unique.
A.I. would never come up with
Vanilla Buys
a Timeshare in Paradise.
-Thank you! I agree.
Some things
still need that human touch.
-And, so, when --
And do these just sort of --
I mean, I'm sure
it's a whole team,
but do you, like --
Do you, like, smell it
and then go into,
like, a fugue state
and then you go, "Vanilla
Buys a Timeshare in Paradise"?
-It just --
Yeah, it just comes to me.
I start, like, shaking
and I'm like...
-You just, like, lie in
a milk bath until --
And then they, like,
plug you in.
-They've infused the room
so I can, like, feel it deeply.
We do so many, like,
walk-throughs,
where we have, like,
multiple spaces
and the sensor plugged in and
they're warm and they're going
and we all are kind of a part
of this process
together of creating the names.
I love that you are
really interested
in the creation of the name.
So much more goes behind it.
-I'm very impressed by it.
And congratulations on that.
Congratulations on the book.
-Thank you.
-And congratulations on --
I'm sure it's going to be
the best Christmas card
of anyone I know.
-I'm gonna send you one.
-You better. You better.
We'll send you one.
Hilary Duff, everyone.
Her new book,
"My Little Sweet Boy,"
is on sale everywhere now,
but please support local
and independent bookstores.
And stick around.
We'll be right back with
Please Don't Destroy.